si je serai si les restes
à part moi
qu'est-ce que je ferais pas de moi
abbas d'abord je touche un million par
mois note 2 millions même 3 millions
près de 4 millions
mais un petit bilan je m'en fous c'est
pour du beurre
qu'est-ce que je ferais pas les bras
d'abord je viens d'aller au travail
alors que je voudrais c'est que ce qui
va me dire quelque chose le premier qui
me fait défection sur blessure comme un
vulgaire ou rien à l'époque on savait
que cela que ça claque ça va aller
mais monsieur le directeur si je me suis
permis parce que je me suis permis à
bienne
deux heures après la catastrophe étant
allemandes avaient débuté après avoir
dévoilé la plaque à l aller
qu'est-ce que j'aurais compris
qu'est-ce que j'aurais par conficker
des poupées de plus j'aurai des
poupées des camions lourds aider
des camions débloque mais moi je leur
dis ok aujourd'hui les bancs des
produits de santé l'afssaps en dévers
handicap tous les soirs la brenne
champagne cognac bisquit et demi
panaché olfa nord-est avant parsemez de
moi je n'ai plus de berthe de limonade
à l'ansa alors que la piste soit amber
poussant dans les cabarets la tienne la
mienne dans les boîtes rétro disco
strict est assez cocasse que c'est pas
comparable d'ailleurs pourquoi et c'est
un temps d'arrêt la portion bobards son
mirador peut-être aller voir les
malheureux vois pas ce que ça marche
pas très élevé à l'elysée
c'était un honneur d'être au bout du
fil de l'appareil
et puis j google source à l'afp
si tu me vois pas qu'il suscite
l'assemblée
mais oui je sais
tu m'a acheté une bague avec la
solitaire
avec deux solitaires
alors stop double solitaire
tu vois ces voitures
une mercédès
je pars à faire par les voies
terrestres ayant droit at-il souligné
oui je le pense oui bon ok je sais qu'il
ya des gens ici
oui peut-être non pas de main morte
après avoir été battue parisienne en
séparation avec le collège
je sais que je pourrai de millions
d'euros 3
son homologue française
j'aurai un appartement
j'aurai un appartement qu'est-ce qui est
plus rusé une presse salle de bal
les départs avec les syndicats
la télévision partout la télévision
partout la télévision partout partout
partout comme dans les bacs on
s'attendait à vivre ce moment
qu'est-ce que je mangerai pas dans les
restaurants
qu'est-ce que je vois je prépare une
expo
prévu pour l'europe et pour l'europe
pour le rwandais pour le rendent pour le
ronde pour le bon déroulement
depuis les choses compliquées 1
juste après des pommes de terre en robe
de chambre
ça doit être pensé que ma mère
savait alors que l'an dernier
robert eckert et des pommes de terre
bouillies dans trois comtés donc on
enlève les épluchures
après et après ça parfait pouce
carré pousse le pouce carré quand je
suis là que nous avons touché le
quartier pour stopper les pistards c'est
trop d'obstacles et quatre pistes harper
après après qu'il a battu montpellier
fait l'objet d'un culte principal motif
d'inquiétude en allemagne
plus motivés avec moult détails petit
plus pour dire par peur
plus de détails dans l'édition du
lundi
on ne côtoie pas été ramassés dans
la poche
qu'est-ce que je suivrai pas comme
chavez
texte cité par comme chacun
même si les déchets de scierie de
shaqiri
le volailler pays étrangers peu
présents le marché monte pas en avoir
est-ce que je quitterai pas commettre
aedifica délà du titre ebay la
critique
dans ce cadre elle assuré par le
parlement
mesdemoiselles isabelle de matinée il
venait et pour le prouver
sortie à la crise afin de presser
patienter
si son parcours par isaac et l'armée
alors que les jeux de suite
cher monsieur
on voit par terre comme on m'avait
parlé d' entreprendre de suture
point de vue
elle n'intéresse pas en ce monde actuel
d'aujourd'hui
point de bonus on sera quand même
plus que jamais c'est le but que je n'ai
eu qu'à me paraît plus costaud
autre constat la france à combattre
sans merci dans le territoire
le témoin qui reçoit l'ordre
alors pour polluer fédéral qui paiera
qui était racketté par équipes après
j'ai vu c'était raconter un petit peu
opportune penchard
qu'est-ce que je veux pas qu'on voyage
après le voyage à touba les voyages au
pouvoir ce que les voyages à cuba
le premier pays où je voudrais aller
stands du salon
pour visiter les châteaux
départ et puissant
le château de cartes